ich bin mir das heutige
Datum 11 von
10 in meinem letzten Vlog wurde ich
gefragt warum ich wenn ich auf dem
Fahrrad unterwegs bin immer so schnell
fahre meiner Ansicht nach gibt es nichts
dümmeres und zeitraubenderes als
langsames von A nach B kommen wenn Leute
in der Stadt laufen und schländern ganz
lang
man verbraucht so viel mehr Lebenszeit
wenn man diese ganzen Wege langsam macht
ich habe nichts zu tun da mache ich ein
Workout fahr schnell Fahrrad wenn ich
irgendwo hingehe gehe ich schneller ich
hasse dieses langsame von A na B komm
dumm
Leute die Beine fast gleich aus du
siehst ein wie Spongebob
[Musik]
junge
lustige Story übrigens zu diesem
Betonklotz hier vorne auf den Ring hat
einfach damals ein Auto geparkt und die
haben das irgendwie nicht abgeschleppt
gekriegt oder irgendwie so und haben das
dann einfach einbetoniert ich weiß nicht
was da gerade für eine Baustelle ist was
sie machen aber das ist einfach ein
einbetoniertes Auto also nur Z Info
falls irgendwer von euch gefragt haben
sollte bitte sprich nur noch Frau
an dann TA plötzlich irendwie random
Hund im Treppenhaus
[Musik]
auf heute sitze ich tatsächlich nicht
auf dieser Couch weil wieder irgendein
irrelevanter Youtuber mein
Namen ich habe ein kleines Spiel
vorbereitet pack mich nicht so an zwei
Lügen eine Wahrheit dann und ich haben
jeweils
drei meine Stories sch dem
Handy und ich haben auf jeden Fall jeder
drei Stories am Start von denen aber nur
eine Story wirklich passiert ist und wir
tragen uns jetzt die gegenseitig vor und
müssen dann erraten welche Story vom
anderen wohl die wahre ist und welche
beiden gelogen sind ich habe an einem
Tag weil ich wie immer Diät machen
wollte und ich nicht wusste was ich
wusste nicht wie meine Diät startet
deswegen habe ich an einem Tag mehr als
30 Äpfel gegessen weil ich dachte das
das einzige ist was gesund ist meine
Story number two ist dass ich auf einer
Party war und die Party relativ
langweilig und da bin ich auf die
schlaue Idee gekommen eine Fake Hochzeit
zu haben und
ja ich habe dann war dann die Person die
geheiratet hat meine dritte
Story ein Lehrer von mir mein damaliger
Physiklehrer hat 60 Minuten lang
Unterricht vergeudet nur mich zu
ärgern okay das sind deine drei
Geschichten ja ich darf natürlich auch
Fragen stellen richtig wo hat die Party
stattgefunden wo du geheiratet hast bei
Stefanie und was war das ihr Geburtstag
oder was einfach so so weil die hatte
sturmfrei ja früher war das doch so zu
viel drin okay ich glaube ich weiß
welche Story wahr ist bevor ich das
allerdings sag sage ich dir meine drei
Stories Story Nummer ein ich habe mal
einen Arzt aufgesucht als Kind mit
meiner m zusammen weil ich eine
Süßigkeit gegessen habe die so im Mund
gekribbelt hat und ich dachte ich hätte
ganz viel Plastik verschluckt
okay während ich am Baden war ja habe
ich mal in die Badewanne reingepisst
okay hab ich auch schon
Gemach klar ich bin nicht dumm habe ich
Ex auf toil aber echt dumm ne wenn du da
drin sitzt und musst pisst du einfach
rein das ist soig man geht nach dem Ben
meistens noch mal duschen weil man dann
sein eigenen
Rotz wofür und die dritte Story ist dass
ich mich mal nicht getraut habe meinem
Bett zu schlafen weil dort eine Spinne
war die ich fangen wollte die dann aber
unters Bett gekrabbelt ist ich bin
direkt aufgestanden hab im Gästebett
geschlafen okay äh wann war das mit dem
ähm mit der Spinne wie alt warst du da
war vor zwei Jahren
äh ist es hier in der Wohnung passiert
nein das war in Hamburg
okay okay
was war das für eine Süßigkeit in der
ersten Story das war so eine so ein
Schoko Ding an Ostern m ja ich war da
ein kleines Kind ich war 5 Jahre alt 6
Jahre alt oder so mhm okay und ja
Badewanne gepisst
ich weiß dass du nie Baden gehst ja ich
weiß ich war in meinem ganzen Leben
vielleicht als Kind war ich ein bisschen
häufiger baden aber das war tatsächlich
in meiner zweiten Wohnung in der ich war
im Innenhof wo ich so eine kleine
Duschbadewanne hatte und da wollte ich
dann baden gehen und dann mir aber
aufgefallen ey so mit der Wärme von dem
Wasser ich muss jetzt irgendwie doll
pissen da ich mir scheiß ich piss
einfach hier rein die Story mit der
Spinne kann auf jeden Fall nicht stimmen
weil du ein Bett hast das auf dem Boden
ist natürlich ist mein Bett in der Luft
ist auf in der Luft ja 10 cm so ah ich
dachte auf dem Boden ich bin mir aber
sicher mit einer Story okay
Story 1 weil du bist ein
hyperhondra du sagst Story 1 mit der S
mit der Süßigkeit ist wahr ja du bist
nämlich ein Hoper hondra okay ich sage
die Story mit den Äpfeln ist wahr
äh bei mir war falsch die Story mit den
Äpfel stimmt nicht dann die mit der
Hochzeit ne nein auch nicht mit dem
Lehrer mit dem Lehrer bei mir war
richtig war das ja ich bin Hal einfach
heftig kackformat machen wir nie wieder
be mir in der Wohnung eine Spinne ist
stelle ich einfach immer so ein Glas auf
die drauf bis sie dann so klein werden
Spinnen werden immer klein wenn die
irgendwie verrecken ne und dann ma ich
mal den hier mit dem
Zettel oh mein Gott die LE
noch oh mein Gott die hat mich komplett
die lebt noch da drin einfach oh
mein Gott was ein komm da kann
ich dir eigentlich
freilassen oh mein Gott da ist er die
ist weg
ey so ein Bastard ne kann ich das jetzt
anfassen ich weiß nicht ob es verboten
ist spinn zu töten oder nicht genauso
wie bei bien ob ich jetzt irgende eine
Strafe Krieg dafür ich habe sie auch
obviously nicht getötet aber es wäre mir
so egal scheiß
drecksvecher ich bin viel zu oft mit
Euch beiden Idioten im
Auto selbschuld ne der FC also der große
fußballferein aus Köln der FC Köln
spielt heute gegen Bayer Leverkusen in
Leverkusen und das ist an alle und euch
keine Ahnung von Fußball haben ein
ziemlich großes Ding weil es das
rheinerby ist und Leverkusen ist halt
gefühlt ein Stadtteil von Köln deswegen
haben kfad und ich uns gesagt dass
wirute ins Stadion gehen den schneiden
wir aus der ist nämlich irgendwie Fan
von der komischen Mannschaft ich weiß
nicht ob man merkt dass das hier heute
ein reinerby und dementsprechend
Hochsicherheitsspiel ist aber es gibt
Anzeichen das
interessante Sprachen lernen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Babbel Spiel ist vorbei
Köln hat 30
verloren schauen wir mal was wird was
wird gelbes
Auto einmal im Jahr benutze ich meine
Sauna und dieser Tag ist heute
gekommen ich berichte in 10 Minuten wie
es
war mir ist so schwindelig zum Abschluss
heutigen Vlogs wollte ich mich dann noch
mal cool mit einer timelapse Filmen wie
ich mir mein Abendessen koche allerdings
brauchte ich für das Rezept mein Handy
was ich dann hier die ganze Zeit gesucht
habe und dann realisiert
[Musik]
habe oh mein
Gott
ich bin der dümmste Youtuber der
Welt ich wollte mir gerade Nudeln mit
scumy Kochen anhand eines Rezepts was
ich die Tage online gefunden habe und
habe gerade die ganze Zeit mein Handy
gesucht ich dachte das wä hier ich habe
sogar ein Kühlschrank geguckt ich lauf
nach unten ich komme nach oben ich denke
nur so hey oder Rezept kann ich jetzt
nicht kochen ich stop erstmal die
Aufnahme da ist ja mein Handy
ihr ihr schaltet jetzt besser ab